complaisance vis-à-vis des artistes
maudit moi j'en ai un peu assez de cette
espèce de romantisme autour de ces stars
cela fait plus de 25 ans qu'on entend
parler de Pierre Palmade soit pour ses
pièces de théâtre soit pour ses phrases
liées à l'alcool et à la drogue Pierre
Palmade est un toxico alors il y en a
des milliers dans l'histoire Jim
Morrison mort dans son vomi Elvis sur
ses toilettes oui ce sont des
toxicomanes le talent n'enlève pas ça il
y a un drame personnel chez palmat c'est
certain mais il y a aujourd'hui une
femme qui a perdu son bébé et un père et
son fils de 6 ans qui sont entre la vie
et la mort alors ce n'est pas seulement
irréparable comme la titrée hier le
journal Le Parisien c'est impardonnable
le traitement médiatique qui a eu au
tout début de l'affaire tout le monde
enfin tous les médias la majorité des
médias ont pensé uniquement à Pierre
Palmade et pas aux victimes donc
évidemment que il y a un traitement qui
est beaucoup trop sympathique avec
Pierre Palmade d'ailleurs qui a été ça a
été le cas pendant des années que ces
interviews complaisantes en disant ah
vous êtes un artiste un écorché vif là
c'est sûr que quand c'est la vie d'une
famille qui est détruite on a envie
d'être beaucoup moins sympathique et
beaucoup moins compréhensif avec lui on
va avoir des nouvelles de cette affaire
qui est encore rebondit aujourd'hui avec
monopoma et Myriam Palomba il y a le
porte-parole du gouvernement aussi
Olivier Véran qui s'est exprimé sur
cette affaire regardez ce qu'il a dit la
nature du stupéfiant qui va être
consommé peut défendre peu dépendre et
en fonction des lieux si vous êtes en
métropole ou en réalité tu profil social
de l'usager moi je ne crois pas qu'il y
ait une tolérance sociale sociétale et
encore moins politique vis-à-vis de
telle ou tel drogue sous prétexte que
telle ou tel public le consomme plus
favorablement la drogue la cocaïne les
opiacées sont des drogues extrêmement
dangereuses avec un pouvoir addictif
extrêmement puissant et qui conduisent à
des drames humains qui nous faut éviter
par tous les moyens
et en 96 je voudrais vous montrer
quelque chose Michel Laroque et PERP
Palmade interprète une pièce elle
s'appelle il s'aime vous connaissez
cette pièce et dedans le sketch du
permis de conduire est terriblement
prémonitoire regardez Pierre Palmade et
vénère contre Muriel Robin qui vient
d'avoir son permis qui ne maîtrise pas
trop encore la voiture regardez
je vais
je suis à 60
c'est la seconde pour voir
[Applaudissements]
elle est beaucoup plus grosse que celle
des leçons alors
reste un peu sur ta droite et au milieu
de la roue il y a personne en face c'est
pas toujours comme ça
alors c'est fou ça c'est incroyable et
il y a quelques jours par Palmade à
poster une vidéo assez étrange dans
laquelle il parle de son espérance de
vie regardez deux fois 5408 c'est à dire
si je suis à la moitié de ma vie
je mourrais à 108 ans et trois fois 54
162 ce qui fait que si je suis un tiers
de ma vie je mourrai à 162 ans mais ça
c'est quand même
peu probable
oui non je suis pas un tiers de ma vie
alors bien sûr tout le monde donne son
avis maintenant sur cette affaire on va
voir des nouvelles éléments dans un
instant même un habitant de chez lui qui
a témoigné puisque tout le monde voilà
il est un habitant voisin à lui qui a
témoigné qui a dit
devenir agressif vulgaire voilà
après tout le monde donne son avis
maintenant aussi c'est toujours comme ça
alors
pierre Palma a évoqué à plusieurs
reprises son addiction à l'alcool et aux
drogues dans les médias et l'un des
moments les plus forts c'est dans On
n'est pas couché sur France 2 regardez
il était complètement conscient qu'un
jour il lui arriverait quelque chose de
grave regardez vous savez pas à 20 ans
que c'était une maladie je crois que
c'est un divertissement je suis beau
doré à 30 ans que c'était un poison à 40
ans j'étais sûr que j'étais cocaïnomane
et que j'allais dans le mur et ça fait
10 ans que j'essaye de d'arrêter tout ce
qu'on fait quand on a bu une bouteille
de vodka et prix de la drogue on est
minable on est voilà j'ai
changé honte de toutes les murs j'ai de
toutes les
et de toutes les consommations de drogue
que j'ai faites sauf que je sais que
maintenant c'est une maladie alors je
peux je serai dépendant à vie mais je
peux être abstinent toute ma vie
c'est-à-dire que si j'évite tous les
pièges je peux à partir d'aujourd'hui
depuis 3 semaines en tout cas je peux ne
plus jamais en prendre de ma vie si je
me démerde pas trop mal
et en septembre 2020 il était venu nous
voir Pierre Palma il était venu sur
notre plateau certains messages sur les
réseaux l'accusé de ne pas être dans son
état normal il avait décidé de répondre
en direct après la pub regardez
non mais depuis un an où j'ai parlé des
problèmes d'accès d'alcool et
toxicomanie dès que je fais un petit
truc un peu fou
il y a encore défoncé
et c'est ça qui m'a sauvé la vie c'est
parce que pour avoir le talent je suis
obligé de ne pas en prendre exactement
donc et puis si j'ai envie de faire ça
ça veut pas dire que je suis beau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dis si l'émission est pas drôle je
dis je mets une jupe et je lui dis bon
je continuerai l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à la famille des victimes exactement et
la famille cette famille qui est
dessinée et c'est vrai qu'on
c'était un garçon c'est un garçon
tellement sympathique père pas mal quand
il est pas dans ses dans ses travers
c'est vrai que voilà on était très
heureux l'avoir ici même ses amis
évoquent ces addictions regardez
Jean-Luc Moreau il a raconté une
anecdote qui ont dit long sur le rapport
de Pierre Palmade à la drogue regardez
j'ai eu un petit souci au début un petit
souci le premier jour de répétition de
la pièce où il y a eu un problème de de
un petit problème de de drogue j'ai même
très surpris d'ailleurs parce que il
m'avait demandé s'emballe pour aller
voir un fournisseur et moi j'ai appelé
son agent en disant si elle n'est pas
possible et la jambe répond mais on va
tout de suite vous rembourser ce qui
hallucinant il aurait dû
je pensais pas qu'ils allaient me dire
ça franchement voilà donc on en parle
Jean-Marie je sais que tu étais très
proche pierre et c'est vrai que voilà je
suis très emmerdé je suis entre le
marteau et l'enclume si tu veux moi je
vois quelqu'un qui a été un ami il peut
pas renier ça je le vois tout sur comme
si venait de se jeter d'une falaise et
je le regarde tomber je ne peux rien
faire rien il n'est pas il n'est pas
rattrapable et il est complètement
coupable c'est extrêmement j'ouvre la
bouche ou je l'enterre et c'est déjà
fait parce que
tu vois vu les circonstances vu tout ce
qui va se passer on va parler dans un
instant il a été entendu aujourd'hui
c'est très très pénible et je renouvelle
à chaque fois mes pensées pour mais
justement pour les victimes toi qui a
arrêté toi tu as arrêté l'alcool il y a
combien de temps là en octobre moi oui
18 octobre
est-ce que un moment tu t'es pas dit que
je vais lui dire tu te sens mieux ah
mais 100000 fois mieux je suis une autre
personne mais si je voulais te dire
quelque chose de plus intime en tous les
amis de Pierre tous ceux qui ont côtoyé
pierre tout sans exception lui en dit
Pierre arrête vraiment tout le monde y a
pas une seule on sait tous cassés les
dents c'est à dire il dit non je fais ce
que je veux arrêter de me dire ce que je
dois faire et donc il a survécu tout ça
et puis là c'est la grosse punition
c'est à dire il y a plus rien à faire il
est arrivé hein il disait genre regarde
moi tu l'as pas dit moi regarde comme je
me sens mieux tu lui dis pas quand tu la
vois au téléphone
pas ces derniers temps parce que c'est
perdu de vue depuis pas mal de temps une
dizaine d'années peut-être même un petit
peu plus non c'est que ce qu'on se
disait c'est que même si on avait ils
étaient arrivés de faire la fête et
peut-être même de se coucher y a pas
d'heure après genre midi après l'after
tu vois de se dire que ça suffit une
seule nuit blanche tu vois mais pas
trois
tu vois c'est à ce rythme là en se
disait d'une part que c'était pas
jouable que Pierre ne pourrait pas
survivre à ça et là il est arrivé un
drame plus que monstrueux parce qu'il se
retrouve responsable de la vie d'autres
personnes donc il est passé
si j'ose dire entre les gouttes
tellement de fois et après tellement
d'interdictions que nous lui avons
signifié que voilà maintenant c'est le
drame et on ne peut que constater
vous allez parler entre vous tous ces
proches ou pas du tout depuis le moi
j'ai curieusement non je n'ai pas
tellement parlé parce que ça nous ramène
tous à cette période tu vois d'amitié il
y a 15 ans je parle et un peu la
prescription là-dessus mais
bien sûr que quand on se souvient de
toutes les fois où on a dit
une nuit blanche ça va deux c'est pas
possible 3 de c'est même plus comment tu
t'appelles tu risque de te baladant dans
la rue de rencontrer d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui s'est passé de rencontrer n'importe
qui c'est cambrioler même tabasser
éventuellement chez soi que tu ramasses
au bout d'une troisième nuit blanche tu
prends des coups d'accélérateur tu vois
pour continuer à tenir debout c'est en
continuant à ingurgiter de de l'alcool
c'est le grand problème de de la cocaïne
quoi c'est que tu une fois que ça a été
une drogue qui a fait des miracles
bien sûr mais une fois bourré
que tu utilises quelque chose qui fait
que tu pues bourré et que donc au lieu
de boire tu vois de boire dit whisky tu
peux en boire 20 et te retrouver à
rentrer en moto moi je suis des fois
rentré en risquant uniquement ma vie à
moi parce que en deux routes tu risques
pas tu vois des d'écraser un bus ou une
voiture mais je je remercie les les fois
où des potes dans la boîte où j'étais
qui m'ont piqué les clés de ma moto pour
me dire bah non tu rentreras pas comme
ça tu rentres en taxi et Pierre la
presque tout le temps fait il avait
quand même la conscience de ça de ne pas
conduire son propre véhicule que te
quand on est un défoncé depuis plus de
48 heures des fois 72
histoire tu es plus heureux maintenant
c'est dire
j'ai l'impression que ça même jamais ça
ne m'est jamais arrivé à ce point que je
suis loin en famille mes enfants et tout
je sais même pas j'aime vraiment
beaucoup de mal à me dire que que j'ai
vécu une période comme énormément de de
gens à l'époque
c'était une espèce de grande mode
pouvait pas aller à l'époque il y a 15
ans dans une boîte sans penser où on
allait aller au moment de la fermeture
directe à 6h on va où après c'est quoi
l'acheteur et c'est où tu vois et
je te dis
heureusement que j'avais un petit
réservoir de de conscience et que on a
tous je dis bien tous tous les amis tous
ceux qui ont fréquenté de très près
pierre ils l'ont sommet de d'arrêter en
disant on peut aller jusqu'à un certain
point mais pas trop loin parce qu'un
jour il va arriver un malheur et ce
malheur est arrivé et maintenant on ne
peut faire autre chose que de le le
l'enfoncer dans le dans le trou dans
lequel il s'est mis quoi alors ce qui
excuse-moi Cyril mais ce qui
m'interpelle dans ce que dit Jean-Marie
c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'il y avait beaucoup
de monde autour de lui en fait ne compte
personne pas même sa famille est
sûrement évidemment des proches tu
aurais peut-être pu l'aider parce que
lorsqu'il parle il a l'air vachement
conscient de ce qu'il est sa maladie etc
il le dit lui-même jusqu'à arriver à ce
que on sait maintenant mais ce
personnage là aurait pu être mis sous
curatelle moi juste un exemple dans mon
village j'ai un gars qui buvait l'alcool
comme un malade et j'étais à deux doigts
de le mettre sous curatelle en tant que
mère j'aurais pu la loi l'autoriser
pour lui c'est qu'il est mort
entre-temps mais c'était un véritable
danger pour nous j'étais prêt à faire
une intervention auprès du préfet pour
dire ce mec là il faut le mettre sous
cette main c'est-à-dire l'enfermé et le
soigner et c'est dommage on a toujours
pensé à ça je pense qu'il a pas eu de
suivi parce que c'est pas normal d'en
arriver là quoi c'est c'est très Bruno
pas une seule pas un seul de ses amis ne
lui ai pas dit alors arrête c'est ça oui
mais sa famille ne voulait pas c'est ça
ce qu'on dit
ses amis voulaient voilà mais c'est ça
on est toujours
sa famille ne voulait pas moi mon
meilleur ami est très proche de pierre
et de Pierre Palmade et que tu dis qu'on
l'a pas aidé il a pas été aidé ils l'ont
tous dit ils l'ont tous dit
effectivement qu'il fallait qu'ils
soient mais quand il était sobre ben oui
il était conjoint qu'il fallait qu'il le
fasse il a fait plein de cure-pierre il
est parti à Boulogne par exemple Tunisie
mais rester trois quatre jours et je
pense que le vrai problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un ami proche pourrait
aider son son prochain on peut pas
décider de le mettre dans un hôpital ou
de ou des traits il y a que la famille
et la famille de là en tout cas jamais
fait et c'est vrai que ça fait deux ans
tous les cas que que Jean-Phi et
d'autres et d'autres mon meilleur ami on
pris conscience que c'était devenu
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement grave
merci alors Myriam palomb parce que ça
rebondit aujourd'hui il est 21h02 en
étant direct qu'en est-il pour Pierre
Palmade aujourd'hui alors Pierre Palmade
a été placé en garde à vue aujourd'hui
donc directement aujourd'hui c'est droit
lui ont été notifiés peu avant 14h à
l'hôpital du Kremlin-Bicêtre où il était
hospitalisé il a été conduit sous escort
policière à l'hôpital de Melun où là il
est entendu par par les par les
policiers il s'agit en fait de faciliter
sa présence il a entendu en ce moment
encore oui il a entendu oui
dans un instant il a été transféré donc
cet après-midi cet après-midi sous
escort policière à l'hôpital de Melun le
but c'est de faciliter sa présentation
devant le juge d'instruction du tribunal
de Melun et puis éventuellement s'il
doit être s'il y a une détention
provisoire qui qui va être décidé par la
suite à l'hôpital pour l'instant non
puisqu'il en garde à vue pendant 48
heures
les familles des victimes ou les
victimes pour l'instant non pas moi de
mes infos j'ai pas j'ai pas ça et là
l'enquête avant sa grand pas parce que
il y a également les deux alors
justement on va on va en parler avec
Bruno parce que Bruno il y a eu des ça a
rebondi aujourd'hui oui donc pire
Palmade est actuellement en garde à vue
oui
l'enquête ne fait que commencer en on va
savoir exactement ce que il va pouvoir
dire aux enquêteurs ça va être un
travail intéressant évidemment pour
connaître également la réalité de ce qui
s'est passé dérouler le fil de
l'histoire comme on dit et surtout les
deux les deux individus qui sont alors
justement oui donc un cliché qui a été
deux individus qui se sont sauvés de la
voiture au moment de l'accident
apparemment sont été en bonne santé donc
ils ont rien eu ils sont plus sortir de
la voiture c'est que ce type là la
voiture ça fait plusieurs jours qu'on
les recherchait qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé se sont rendus ou alors il y en a
un qui a été interpellé qui est un jeune
marocain 34 ans sans papier d'après ce
que les informations sont est-ce que
c'est un escort-girl une situation
irrégulière
on ne sait pas encore les éléments dans
lequel nous me diront normalement c'est
un escorteil qui l'a rencontré sur les
réseaux sociaux en fait qui a été
interpellé hier à Clichy-la-Garenne en
fait il était hébergé par une dame et
grâce à l'analyse du portable de Pierre
Palmade ils ont réussi à le repérer et
ils sont allés l'arrêter ce matin 6h30
le deuxième ce qui est intéressant dans
la deuxième c'est qu'il est connu des
services de police pour pour les
problématiques de stupéfiants donc ça va
être très intéressant pour les policiers
évidemment de voir si derrière il y a un
réseau aussi parce qu'il y a tout un
travail qui est fait au-delà de
l'enquête à proprement parler il y a
tout un travail qui va être fait par les
enquêteurs qui sont nombreuses et ce
type d'affaires parce qu'il faut fermer
toutes les portes et ça c'est un c'est
un travail qui est essentiel pour les
enquêtes pour savoir un petit peu ce qui
s'est passé aussi pourquoi ils sont
partis parce que non assistance à
personne engagée il faut savoir que ça
coûte cher aussi c'est 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et 75000 euros d'amende
ce qui le mériteraient alors justement
parce que vous pouvez venir au
téléspectateurs donc il y a trois
personnes en garde à vue il y a un homme
donc soupçonné d'être l'un des deux
passagers de la voiture donc vous avez
dit c'est un marocain de 33 ans inconnu
lui des services de police mais sans
papiers apparemment et la femme qui
hébergeait depuis plusieurs jours a
également été interpellé à son domicile
c'est important elle a été elle a été
interpellée en même temps que que le que
le que le juge soit le le premier fuya
c'est ça qui s'appellerait mossine voilà
et qui aurait aussi une et qui aurait 33
ans
en amont il y a un avocat qui est venu
alors
les policiers sont montés à lui car la
veille de l'accident cet homme s'est
rendu dans la pharmacie à proximité pour
acheter des seringues c'est ce qui est
dit aussi donc ça c'est extrêmement
important aussi cette ce petit point et
cet après-midi donc le deuxième passager
a fait savoir aux enquêteurs par le
billet de son avocat qu'il souhaitait se
rendre le procureur de Melun a fait
savoir qu'il y a quelques minutes le
deuxième fuillère a été également placé
en garde à vue et comme vous l'avez dit
lui il était connu des services de
police pour des faits de stupéfiants
pourquoi ils sont alors ils sont ils
sont rapatriés sur Melun comme le disait
Paloma parce que le tribunal compétence
et Melun et surtout la direction
départementale de la sécurité publique
peut assurer la sécurité de ces deux
individus qui sont évidemment dans un
service de police et qui seront
évidemment auditionnés dans qui doivent
d'ailleurs auditionner c'est à 13h55
précisément qu'il a été placé en garde à
vue Pierre Palmade son état alors
psychologie ils estiment qu'il est apte
voilà à subir un interrogatoire après
psychologiquement il est extrêmement
surveillé il va il va très mal et et
évidemment les gens ont peur qu'ils se
suicident ou qu'ils fassent un acte qui
le condamne à jamais et visiblement s'il
a donc été interrogé ça veut dire que
les médecins parce que c'est eux les
compétents là dedans qui peuvent donner
le top pour pouvoir l'interroger ça
c'est très important il faut le prendre
en compte apparemment il n'y aurait pas
mis donc de télé dans sa chambre pour
qui voilà c'est une vraie garde à vue
dans l'hôpital en fait dans 48 heures il
a que ça a rien il voit personne ils
essaient de créer au maximum les
conditions d'une garde à vie normale
d'accord et il est interrogé depuis
13h55
on lui signifie la garde à vue et puis
c'est parti
à l'hôpital sur Melun effectivement il
est il est interrogé le non-stop où on
le laisse se reposer les enquêteurs
reviennent enfin il y a tout à l'heure
mais sans doute avec des pauses
lorsqu'il est
tu en pause il est tout seul quand il a
interrogé sur les faits il est
possiblement accompagné d'un avocat et
pour le moment il est en garde à vue
donc 24 heures qui peuvent être
renouvelées pour 48 pour homicide des
blessures involontaires par conducteur
sous l'emprise de stupéfiant c'est à
dire que pour le moment il y a l'omcide
involontaire quand même qui reste ou
volontaire voilà il reste ouvert et à
propos des deux fuyards il faut noter
que il risque non pas 50 mais 7 ans de
prison pour non-assistance en personne
en danger parce qu'il y avait un mineur
qu'ils auraient pu secourir ça alourdi
donc très vraisemblablement voilà très
vraisemblablement le deuxième qui a
appelé la police avec son avocat à
essayer de
passer cet appel pour tenter après
possiblement d'alléger sa peine en
disant vous voyez j'ai fait la démarche
de voilà mais ça peut ça peut servir ses
intérêts dans le dans le futur voilà
d'accord de toute façon il avait été
quand même repéré par les policiers il
avait vraiment identifié grâce au
téléphone de de Pierre Palmade écarte
bleue téléphonique
et du coup il y en a je pense qu'il a
dit comme je sais que je vais être
intercepté je tente de dire je vais me
rendre voilà alors est-ce qu'on sait ce
qui se passe avec le monde Bruno vous
avez beaucoup de notes je m'en sors
plusieurs
la mise en examen qui va qui va arriver
automatiquement le juge d'instruction va
signifier à Monsieur Palma évidemment
assez droit ça c'est essentiel ce qui va
être est-ce qu'il peut ressortir de
l'hôpital
où est-ce que il va être
toute la question est là c'est une vraie
question moi je pense que compte tenu du
profil du personnage parce que les faits
divers comme ça malheureusement il y en
a beaucoup en France bien sûr ce type de
d'accident je dirais alors justement 700
personnes qui se touchent sur les routes
avec ça ça c'est intéressant pour noter
les spectacles là si c'est une personne
normale c'est pas Pierre Palmade est-ce
qu'elle est en détention
garde à vue la procédure est la même
24 heures et 48 heures normalement il y
a pas de détention provisoire ou dans ce
cadre-là
donc là donc là Pierre Palmade il peut
avoir une détention provisoire parce que
il sera mis ou sur ami je dirais sous
contrôle médical parce que vous avez
quand même non mais juste Bruno vous
avez vu des trucs si c'est pas perd pas
de made la même histoire est-ce que il y
a une détention provisoire ou pas ça
peut sur le cas euh effectivement
c'est important de le dire c'est ça va
déterminer d'ailleurs le Messie de
volontaire ou involontaire c'est-à-dire
la volonté de de tuer c'est-à-dire
est-ce que Pierre Palma n'a pas pris sa
voiture non mais oui mais non mais non
tout ça ça va rentrer
c'est est-ce que Pierre Palmade a
délibérément jeté sa voiture non mais
tous ces éléments vont être mis en avant
par les enquêteurs quoi est-ce que je
sais pas est-ce qu'il a voulu peut-être
se suicider non mais on n'en sais rien
attendez est-ce qu'il a perdu le
contrôle parce qu'il était bourré ou
d'accord parce que le mec c'est déjà
touché
intentionnelle non non ça va très loin
donc est-ce que il a été encore une fois
je me dis cet homme ici il est
volontaire ou pas alors toute la
question alors si c'est volontaire c'est
combien
il y a le lien avec les circonstances
aggravantes c'est à dire s'il y a une
circonstance aggravante les tubes s'il y
a les excès de vitesse ça part de 5 ans
c'est en 10 ans de prison c'est c'est
c'est ça peut aller loin 5 ans c'est
comment dire le délit de base et ce qui
risque c'est un c'est avec une une
circonstance à gravante ça y est la
lecture s'il y a un excès de vitesse
dessus etc tout ça l'enquête de
gendarmerie routière le le pouvoir
évidemment avec les éléments sur les
voitures etc et tout ça ça s'accumule
les circonstances agrandes font que bah
il peut prendre 10 ans de prison et
grosso modo sans 150000 euros d'amende
voilà donc ça les circonstances vont
être déterminés au cours de l'enquête
Gilles et le fait qu'il soit placé en
détention ou sous contrôle judiciaire
quand même nous donnera une vraie
tendance par rapport aux premières
analyses des faits que les enquêteurs
juste d'instruction auront ça créera un
débat c'est sûr alors une tendance qui
pourrait être privilégiée enfin une
possibilité c'est contrôle judiciaire
avec injonction de soins très sérieux et
très répété
chez lui mais avec voilà interdiction de
sortir et des soins répétés et ça ça
pourrait être aussi et vous sortirez
quoi à la fin de la garde à vue
normalement oui
24 ou 48 si il dit tout en 24 heures on
peut ne pas renouveler pour les 24
heures supplémentaires
du coup le mettre
ici mais les médecins ont un doute aussi
dans son état de santé actuel
pourrait-il supporter une détention
provisoire et ça ça peut jouer en sa
faveur
que ça cet accident et puis exactement
ce qu'il a dit à sa sœur c'est quand
même grave il a dit j'ai fait la pire
des choses donc ce gars était déjà de
nature en dépression j'ai l'impression
je pense que avec ça un élément
complémentaire qui peut être décisif
donc c'est très compliqué et pour le
juge et pour les enquêteurs encore une
fois de prendre les bonnes décisions
mais je pense que dans ce cas là et en
plus il y a encore une fois il y a le
fait que on en parle depuis une semaine
évidemment sur les médias etc donc les
enquêteurs sont atteints du tournoi au
même titre que le juge après les
victimes aussi parce que quand on a eu
l'avocat hier ils ont dit bah les
victimes aimerait bien qu'il aille en
prison c'est aussi à la volonté des
victimes
ils disent que depuis les gens disent
que depuis octobre dernier il était très
déprimé il s'est mis en retrait de son
entourage j'avais replongé dans la coke
et les rencontres sexuelles via internet
c'est ça c'est et d'ailleurs les les
deux jeunes gens qui ont été interpellés
sont des sont effectivement des des
escort boys qu'il a rencontré sur les
réseaux sociaux et qu'il a fait venir
chez lui dès le jeudi soir ils ont fait
de la fête ensemble pendant 24 heures à
base de sexe et de cocaïne et on sait
l'issue qui a eu qui a eu cette fête
d'accord et vous savez combien ils
étaient ils étaient juste trois ou non
ils étaient quatre visiblement il y
avait deux autres personnes avec eux il
y avait une personne en plus de Pierre
Palmade quatre personnes
c'est en cours c'est ça fait partie de
l'enquête pour l'instant on n'a pas
vraiment on n'a pas vraiment d'infos sur
ça mais effectivement les les enquêteurs
cherchent également ces deux personnes
environnement quand c'est ça c'est lié
en bière où il habite les gens qui
tournent partout il y a des
perquisitions qui sont faites qui sont
peut-être par les enquêteurs
d'éléments qui font que ça va permettre
aux enquêteurs il est possible qu'ils ne
se souviennent plus de rien
ben vu la bête traumatisme crânien
ne produit
chimiques comme ça etc est-ce que c'est
c'est une de ses proches a dit il y a
deux jours mais il ne se souvenait plus
de la façon ça s'était passé
perte de mémoire totale pour ça que les
inquiétants encore une fois en gros
travail de recherche à faire les deux
individus interpellés là c'est une très
bonne chose parce qu'ils vont pouvoir
balancer dire les choses qu'il fallait
il y a la perquisition qui a qui a où on
a on a su également que une annexe avait
été visitée aussi bon et voilà donc ça
veut dire qu'il y avait quelque chose à
cacher sûrement très bien donc le
travail va être long et ça va mobiliser
beaucoup de beaucoup d'enquêteurs pour
trouver le pour avoir la vérité fait la
vérité elle est elle est là et
malheureusement une famille qui est
quasiment décimée